do you remember when Google announced
duet AI in Google Cloud at this year's
Google I O if not here's a refresher
duet AI for Google cloud is an always-on
AI collaborator that'll help developers
within the IDE the cloud console or
directly within chat it's not just a
one-off tool but an entire system of
tools to help you build applications in
the cloud allowing you to spend time
focusing on what matters
if you'd like to try things out for
yourself and be the first to be notified
on when you can use these products
here's a hot tip check out the link in
our description to sign up to join
Google Cloud's AI trusted tester program
it's where people can learn about
experience and give feedback on Google's
emerging AI Technologies want more sneak
peeks keep an eye on this channel as we
count down the days to next 2023